[Music]
I'm joining my life Selena Gomez is
keeping those good vibes going source
telling et that she isn't fazed by X
Justin Bieber's engagement Baldwin oh no
I go back to you the tourists lzt the
back to you singer does not care at all
that her ex popped the question to
baldwin over the weekend adding quote
Selena is in such a great place and is
surrounding herself with good positive
people and Justin and Haley's happiness
doesn't take away from her own happiness
I feel like you could be able to see it
in my face and I love what I'm doing
right now and I'm getting to do things
that I'm passionate about with the
people that I love
in fact our source says Selena doesn't
have a mean bone in her body and wants
nothing but happiness for Justin and
Haley adding that she has paired things
down lately and has a better perspective
on life so now that she's removed
herself from the Hollywood bubble cell
did seem relaxed boding over the weekend
in NY he check her out rocking a bikini
and hanging with her pal theresa selena
and Justin have dated on and off for
years and most recently earlier this
year just last week at the premiere of
Hotel Transylvania 3 Selena told ET
she's all about cutting stress out of
her life I think in general I think it's
important just to remain positive and
I don't know I come out I'm at that age
where I feel like that's what matters is
making sure I'm healthy and people are
happy that I love
[Music]